ça commence bien mais c'est ça je compte
pas y voir vous présente comment grand
blond will hayes bleus favoris pour sa
yeuse la barbe plus c'est nouveau et
c'est nouveau et c'est pas pour nous non
ce jeu parfait ça depuis ce matin je
m'attends pire c'est toujours aussi
drôle en sorte de laisser aller attendez
que je ne travaille plus je tiens si je
suis toujours aussi drôle je pense que
je suis drôle mais il est trop narvik
bon je pense que tous les enfants qui
sont là ont vais vous poser des
questions parce que ça fait l'unanimité
pierre richard pierre richard
alors qui va poser une question au
premier tient aux deux voilà qui n'est
pas un micro j'ai déjà essayé l'espace
de commentaires non j'ai une jolie voix
quand je chante doucement
dès que je monte un peu où je descends
un peu 3g une voie sur trois notes quoi
oui belle on veut faire un dessin c'est
déjà pas mal
oui c'est peuvent pas mal donc c'est pas
suffisant alors j'ai effectivement j'ai
travaillé il ya eu l'année une époque
des maisons de disques qui voulait
absolument me faire chanter quand ils
ont commencé à me parler de tourner ça
me paraissait trop fastidieux c'est
pourquoi j'avais personnel
il ya beaucoup de comédiens qui chante
ça suffit comme ça oui ma femme et ses
chants enchanteurs
qu'est ce qui peut poser une question
encore à pierre voilà tu me rappelles
tournon véronique quand vous rêviez vous
riez pour de vrai
parce que là je rêve pour le fondre tu
veux dire dans les films idrissi ou de
toute façon je ris très facilement et
c'est vrai qu'il ya des jours où on n'a
pas envie de rire et j'ai une scène où
je dois rire mais ça me vient
si c'est plus facile pour moi de rire
que de pleurer jeunechamp maïdo fait
plus mal de simuler des pleurs comme ça
au à la seconde près mais je peux y
arriver aussi mais alors il faut tout un
contexte d'émotion parce que le rire
c'est plus spontané ça peut venir sur la
même là la tête de mon partenaire ou à
la tête du metteur en scène
mais quand je la regarde et qui font
qu'ils me posez encore une question à
faire à la sofica on te passe le micro
savoir que vous attend tout métier
beaucoup d'argent c'est comme ça je ne
sais pas moi c'est pas c'est une réponse
qui va là mais c'est quand même pas la
première
ça m'apporte je dire si je faisais pas
ça je sais pas ce que je ferai alors ça
m'a pesé ma vie je sais pas si ça
m'apporte ça m'apporte ça m'apporte de
de rire de d'aimer la vie parce que
sinon je serais complètement paumé là
c'est tout quant à une question à poser
tiens prend le micro voilà aulas comment
lui est venue votre comique
enfin je serais tenté de dire ça c'est
mes parents voulaient pas que je fasse
ça et tu pourras d'ailleurs comme ça les
tient pour la tête attention il voulait
pas que je fasse ça mais dans certaines
maisons à quand j'avais 12 ans on me
disait toujours et pour être plein de
petits poèmes pour le décès et
finalement cette petite chose anodine
est devenue très dangereuse pour les
parents qui voulaient surtout pas que je
fasse le métier parce que à force de
dire des poèmes puis de plus en plus
même dès mercredi rld et cyrano de
bergerac puis comme je voulais pas on
m'a dit si tu le dis on offrir un
costume alors je me suis retrouvé
carrega costumes et puis j'ai a dû
apprendre mon texte et puis finalement
je me suis retrouvé dans la peau d'un
acteur c'est à dire que au dessert on
allait me mabille et puis ma mère disait
mes amis ce soir vous aurez quand ça
ressemblait déjà une grande présentation
puis moi j'étais derrière la porte
commencé à dire ils ont l'air bons ce
soir toi petit à petit j'ai attrapé les
les trucs des et puis j'ai dit cyrano de
bergerac j'ai entendu des rires et faut
croire qu inconsciemment d'avoir entendu
des rires dans la salle face à lire à
table et quinze convives qui pouvait
voir les vins saaq très comme moi et une
envie de faire rire probablement
peut-être pas au début évidente mais à
force de dire cyrano de bergerac j'ai
commencé à le peaufiner toi je faisais
de plus en plus rire finalement ce
parcours besoin est
je crois que c'est ça qui m'a donné
envie c'est ça ta question rendement
plus jeune maman et pouvant atteindre la
part c'est un peu court jeune homme on
pourrait dire bien des choses en somme
par exemple tony keller après justement
à partir tenez les plus rien me lis tu
veux poser une question avez vous déjà
tourné des films dramatiques
j'ai pas tourner des films vraiment
dramatique que j'ai détourné des films
qui était moindre
j'ai tourné un film que je veux bien que
ça plaît à nuages entre les dents qui
n'est pas un film vraiment que des
toiles qui est parlons plus dramatique
mais où il y avait beaucoup plus de
gravité puis peut être le jouet est un
film qui fait rire parfois mais qui au
fond assez cruel et assez assez graves
de la vie c'est un film qui pas
dramatique mais qui est un petit peu
plus mais j'ai pas vraiment de tourner
le film dramatique
barbara ça peut être toi tout est rémois
je ne serai pas tout seul pour la b
s'ils doivent ou non sont les autres
courriers moi je me fais pas très riche
la malle à la une question tarif qui il
être vraiment stérile
avis temps en temps d'abord si mon
métier je le fais je crois que j'ai fait
avec sérieux
c'est à peine de rires c'est vrai ce que
je fais à la piscine que je suis un
imbécile et du donc je le fais avec
sérieux je veux dire je suis à l'heure
je suis là on m'a dit et puis et puis il
ya des choses aussi je fais avec sérieux
quand même il ya des choses graves ou
louve en tout ce que je peux ressentir
je me sens pas uniquement que le le le
plaisir d'un d'un gag ou d'une d'une
chose amusante
elodie je me posais une question si ça
ressemble un petit peu à la question
mais c'est pas tout à fait où je fais
des films un peu différent chez les
filles qui sont complètement parfois des
films de gars comme le coup du parapluie
et puis je fais des films justement un
peu plus graves comme le comme le
le jouet ou bien les films un peu plus
d'une comédie john moore un peu un peu
plus c'est pas anglais mais tu vois d'un
humour un peu plus subtil je sais pas
quand mais grand blond aux questions
n'ont rien c'est ça dépend de mes
humeurs et puis de ce conte de deux
circonstances vous fait pour devenir
acteur commencé pour devenir acteur à
moi comment j'ai fait alors là ça va
commencer selon là j'ai donc été acteur
pour la première fois devant mes parents
et puis un jour quand je leur ai dit que
je voulais être acteur vous voulez plus
du tout que je passe aux concernées
alors j'ai quitté la table je suis parti
et j'étais dans un cours du lin le corps
du lacet pour villard plus exactement
c'est à coup d'envoi l'attique et puis
[Musique]
un beau jour il ya un jean vilar est
arrivé il a dit tout le monde se lève
tout ça dit lui lui lui c'est pas comme
ça lance il prenait tout l'est m les
types de mètre 80 je faisais juste un
mètre 80 j'ai été pris au tnp et gg
pour faire de la figuration et j'ai vu
jouer gérard philipe je vais jouer maria
casarès c'était pour moi la meilleure
des manières des écoles mais c'est pas
comme ça je suis venu comédien mais je
te raconte juste le début parce que
sinon ça peu longs carine veut poser une
question combien d'heures travaillées
par semaine ou deux ça n'est pas rien et
cela ne me fait rien du tout non mais ça
dépend il ya des fois je fais quand on
fait un film je travaille comme un
salarié normal c'est à dire s'il faut à
8 48 voix et puis c'est vrai que tout
accouche le plus de films j'en fais pas
pendant deux mois ou trois mois et alors
là je deviens un chômeur privilégier ce
qui est un peu contradictoire mais c'est
à dire que c'est vrai que pendant 2 3
mois j'ai rien à faire c'est un truc que
je te recommande un roulement
céline également eu mes amis c'est
épouvantable oui je crois que je suis
très distrait c'est pour ça n'aurait pas
fait notre métier j'ai failli en faire
pas mal j'ai failli en faire je veux
dire je n'ai jamais fait dans mes rêves
non mais ggg vendu à un moment donné où
j'étais vraiment dans le besoin j'ai
vendu des voitures gt dit viré parce que
je revenais pas d'abord j'étais trop
timide
en plus j'y connais rien en mécanique
mes joueurs
j'avais des velléités comme ça de les
vendre et
donc j'ai connu trois mois à une
question après même temps allez-vous me
pour jouer le coup du parapluie trois
mois et demi a toujours cette eau est
vite battue sept mois et demi pour un
film c'est plutôt l'oim
d'habitude les films séville semaine
neuf semaines et demie des voûtes en
france vous avez toujours envie d'être
acteurs non non je te dis là les laits
c'est un peu inconscient et les vendeurs
de mon problème de raconter mes poèmes à
ma famille après ça m'a fait rester un
peu dans le flou et puis un beau jour
j'ai j'ai fait l'école buissonnière
une chose encore que je vous recommande
ce pour deux mois
j'ai fait l'école buissonnière et j'ai
été voir un film de danic et je pars je
crois pas que vous connaissiez danic et
mais c'était une énorme vedette
américaine de l'époque c'était un type
du grand blond et des yeux bleus comme -
je me suis appuyé l'idée en identifie à
lui à ce moment là je vais dire que
j'étais complètement transporté quand je
les ai vus faire ce qu'il faisait et je
me suis dit j'ai compris maintenant ça y
est j'ai c'est elle eu le coup de foudre
j'ai dit ça y est j'ai compris c'est ça
que je veux faire s est venu en une
après-midi de nuit après midi de cinéma
peut-être passé à l'intérim qui n'a pas
mis dans certaines chaînes indigente
comment faites vous pour garder votre
sérieux et alors vous voyez quand je
suis vraiment je suis vraiment sérieux
c'est vrai c'est plus difficile de fouet
à garder peut-être plus au théâtre
d'ailleurs parce que tu sais qu'on ne
rit jamais autant que là où on doit pas
rire dans les enterrements
j'ai beaucoup de mal sur une scène de
théâtre en classe quand il fait lé pari
roues à l'armée quand c'est vrai que
c'est dans les moments les plus serrées
que qu'on a que moi personnellement mais
je crois que c'est un peu tout le monde
a envie d'aller au théâtre c'est vrai
que j'ai beaucoup de mal à garder mon
sérieux il suffit d'un il suffit d'un
type qui bredouillent qui avait un trou
puis je me vois ses narines toi aussi
tout est d'un type qui a envie de rire
aussi bon soit il fait savoir
ça c'est la résistible alors ici que je
vois un type calais marine qui
s'élargissent et moi je suis partie aux
cyclones yonne aussi fort pour ça et
puis alors on s'écarte comme ça tous les
deux et on parle c'est vrai que garder
son sérieux c'est invisible au cinéma
c'est plus facile parce que justement on
n'a pas la notion de danger au cinéma on
peut recommencer
c'est la notion de dorje qui donne des
fous rires mais on va vous poser une
dernière question va donner la parole à
une charmante petite fille elodie elodie
frégé serbie
que que des films dramatiques je crois
qu'on ne préfère pas vraiment anti c'est
souvent dans la peintre pourquoi hutin
il va dire je sais pas je dénonce et
même à droite
enfin je parle comme ça moi je sais pas
très bien je ne sais pas un choix c'est
une question de nature mais je voudrais
vous poser une question à vous la petite
fidèles parce qu'il s'en aille a dit non
mais si je n'ai pas aimé les enfants je
ne pense pas qu'on me dit on voudrait qu
est-ce que c'est aurore oui j'aime les
enfants mais je ne sais pas parce que
j'aime les enfants je pense que c'est
parce que j'en suis un peu à moi même
j'ai pas si j'ai beaucoup vieilli
non je parle pas physiquement je suis
toujours resté un peu irresponsable
comme les enfants
[Musique]